hazel brucker der comedy-star mit dem
pokerface eine meisterin des finsteren
hungers ihre geschichten spannen sich
von der geburt bis zum tod war möglich
aber würde ich natürlich gebucht und
trotz einzige wo absolut relevant ist
für jede will das ist einzige wohl jedem
ort
sie selbst kommt 1993 in den usa zur
welt wächst im zürcher unterland auf
kaum angefangen geht's steil und schnell
aufwärts
als 19-jähriger wird broker schweizer
meisterin im poetry slam
bald folgt ihr erstes abendfüllendes
bühnenprogramm
[Applaus]
stellen sie sich mal ein schweizer
diktator vor also wie soll denn das
aussehen wer soll denn das machen dj
bobo oder roger federer mehr haben wir
einfach nicht ihr studium bricht sie
vorerst ab lieber plant brucker
auftritte auf papier
schreibt unter anderem für das magazin
kolumnen die schließlich in einem buch
erscheinen seit ihren auftritten bei der
satirische heute show avanciert broker
im deutschsprachigen raum zur
berühmtheit
als reporterin mischt sie sich unter
politiker gespart hatte ich bin keine
und ich würde auch wahrscheinlich die
eine sein
drucker räumt ab was es in ihrer branche
zu gewinnen gibt darunter auch den
renommierten salzburger stier ein
beliebter gast in tv satire formaten zu
trinken da ich neben wasser gerne wasser
trinkt keinen alkohol ja nicht mit so
vielen alten männer und gleichzeitig so
jung so erfolgreich hat gut lachen
trotz poker face hat humor humor setzt
ewigkeit
das heißt humor ist das versucht mit 1 0
ich bin wirklich sich nicht wohlfühlt in
zu große gruppe sozial also wenn so ein
portal wo mehr als zahlen sind natürlich
mich gar nicht wohl
sie können gern so maximal fünf litern
hub los angeles ihre und zu streuen aber
nur trist wie troja damit ich meinen
beitrag leisten zudem sprechen nicht von
mir preisgeben was mussten priester oft
bühne
damit es überhaupt für die persönliche
briefe ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig
war man blüten zum lachen bringen
längerfristig mit mit einem mittel wir
haben das ist einfach meine stimme und
körper
dass man sich einigermaßen verlässlich
macht also dass man sagt hey mir wichtig
dass ihr lachen machen dann nämlich das
persönlich und dann tut es mir weh und
dann will ich das aber sollte jetzt eine
persönliche klasse also falls das noch
einmal passieren sollte heute abend wenn
jemand alleine anfängt zu klatschen
bitte klatschen sehr einfach mit weil es
ist so mehr bericht jedes mal das herz
so ein bisschen wenn jemand in einem
ausverkauften haus alleine an fekter
klasse offensichtlich ist diese person
ja total sozial inkompatibel also
gaststätten das als technik so selber
erarbeitet oder gitarre wie die tore in
anspruch nimmt als coach also ein
direkter coach auch nicht nötig glaube
es das gibt es auch in der schweiz nicht
wirklich aber ich nur gehört sehr viel
komme die geräte auch sehr viel luft und
dann merkt man ja so was funktioniert
und was einem lied und dann habe ich
schon so viele freunde mir ab und zu
sagen hey mach das mal anders oder das
ist schon recht gut und wichtig dass man
offen bleibt für vier anträge und
vorschläge
ich bin eigentlich eine wahnsinnig nette
person
gefangen im körper von jemandem der
überhaupt nicht nett ist also der
medizinische fachausdruck dafür ist rems
sympathisch zudem oft liebe kretas
improvisieren eindruck wie die wichtig
ist die das mittlerweile sehr wichtig
also merke ich dass das bisher schon ich
mir nie will komplett vorbei also ich
will hier in ein bisschen gefahr
massiver nicht witzig frech und bewegen
und da waren das nur zwei minuten sind
von möglichkeit geben hier ist ein
notizbuch das sieht jetzt für das
ungeübte auge so aus als müsste ich
notizen lesen das stimmt natürlich nicht
ich bin profi
hier sind einfach bilder drehen die mich
so ein bisschen beruhigen
ich bin sonst so eine überdrehte
personen und brauche da ab und zu mal
eine optische stütze die mich relax das
sind jetzt heute abend hier rasierte
tiere beim sport sich ein südschweizer
unterwegs dann zum beispiel in
deutschland und ich das gefühl das ist
schon ziemlich gap teil wie so was blüht
wir verstand wurde
dazu findet findet sprache lustig will
mit ihrer show serie sozialisiert das
tut mir leid wenn sie gehört haben dass
ich aus der schweiz komme und jetzt sind
sie enttäuscht
wieso redet sie nicht noch behindert
ich habe mir das ab trainiert ich habe
es mir mühselig ab trainiert aber ich
weiß natürlich es gibt diesen fetisch
ich will den auch bedienen und deswegen
begrüße ich sie ganz kurz auf
schweizerdeutsch damit wir das abgehakt
haben mich gott interessanten extreme
lang hektar drei mini fällig wozu die
letzte träne erfülle ich drifte helge
schneider wie ich es super das ist
erstens supertyp menge lustiger mensch
natürlich unendlich aber irgendwie auf
eine art aber auch dass die beste ort um
sich wünsche
ich werde für dich auch ist berufliches
vorbild also der helge schneider
jedenfalls berufliches vorbild für
mehrere begonnen die damen sind dass ich
das machen will was er macht wieder
erschien erster linie einfach verdammt
gute musik und das bin ich nicht was ich
halt sehr schön findet helge schneider
ist dass er neue max otte im
deutschsprachigen raum gleitet für das
humor des unternehmens will humor und
sicher sitzen helge schneider geht mir
meine genau weniger legitimieren
daher gehe ich auch so gut und so lustig
dass man gar nicht gefragt was ist denn
ihr die nachricht hat waldmann sie
trotzen closing hier wird das frage und
ich jogge bis neu ist sie dann hat man
im koran stehe und dann hat er mir bis
jetzt waren einfach und dann als graveur
anschauen werkstatt und im mittel will
zwar nicht einfach das behielt dem zug
gesessen und hat die vier senioren die
titel wirke stille wie helge schneider
nein ich glaube nicht dass es gut geht
wo mit ricola deutschland hier von coca
cola original